I'm about to
continuing in the book of fasting
from
the chapter regarding the calf.
This here is to mention that the prophet
was selling
would
strongly encourage
that a person
take particular care and make particular
effort
to
make salah
for the duration or for
large portion
of the nights
of the last 10
of Ramadan.
[Silence]
Bukhari and Muslim Abu Hurairah narrates
that the prophet Sallallahu alaihi
wasallam said
whoever
spends the duration
of the night of Laylat al-Qadr which
again we don't know exactly which night
it is each year.
So the only
possible way for a person to conceivably
be certain
of
having
you know acquired its virtue is to have
put in an effort each of the last 10
nights of Ramadan.
He says whoever
does qiyam on the night
of al-Qadr Laylat al-Qadr
out of iman
and hopefulness
in Allah's reward, what is past of his
sins will be forgiven.
[Silence]
Here he says and i'tikaf is only to take
place in a masjid.
Person couldn't make i'tikaf in his home
or i'tikaf in
a small musalla or something that.
It has to be a masjid and a masjid has a
different ruling than a musalla.
And so
some of the scholars have
mentioned that one of the parameters of
a masjid to make i'tikaf in is that it
has to be a masjid that at least is
sizable enough that they give the
Jumu' khutbah.
That they have salat al-Jumu' there at
the masjid.
And so
it has to be in the masjid. Some
scholars
from amongst the tabi'in as a very few
of them
have mentioned that it can only be in
the three major masajid.
Al-Masjid al-Haram, al-Masjid
al-Nabawi, wal Masjid al-Aqsa. That
I'tikaf can only be in those three
masajid. And whilst that opinion is
nothing to thumb your nose at, it does
have its very strong evidences.
Though it is the opinion of the
majority, the minority. The opinion of
the majority of the scholarship of Islam
khalafan wa salafan is that
I'tikaf is permissible in any
masjid.
however, in those three masajid, it
is agreed upon to be
of the utmost of virtue.
And the evidence that I'tikaf can only
be in a masjid is the statement of Allah
"walatubashiruhunna waantum 'aakifuna
fil masajid". So, he mentions al-I'tikaf
in masajid.
And because the Messenger of Allah
sallallahu alayhi wasallam was never
narrated to have ever made I'tikaf
anywhere but a masjid. It's always been
in a masjid. Yaqul
an yashghala nafsahu bita'atillahi kas
salati wal qira'ati wat tasbihi wat
tahmidi wat tahlili wat takbiri wal
[Arabic recitation]
strongly recommended that
a person who is making itikaf spend his
time in in fervent worship of Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala
whether that be in salah or making
thicker or recitation of the Quran or
dua or studying Islamic knowledge etc.
etc.
[Silence]
He said and it is conversely
disliked and dispraised that a person
spend his time
in that which is
unnecessary that which is
little consequence
whether that be of actions or words
while they are in itikaf. Likewise
it is impermissible to take that to the
extreme
to the point that a person refuses to
speak at all to anyone as long as they
are in itikaf. This is well is not the
prophet
Muhammad's sunnah.
[Silence]
And it is permissible for a person
while they are in I'tikaf
that they leave their I'tikaf to go do
something that is necessary
for their
day-to-day, right? And when we say
day-to-day, we're not talking about
you know, going to the bank or
do
of their
doesn't have a place
come to
something
possible for the
brushing their hair or
cutting their
clean
It is
lifted.
Number one,
I'tikaf or
These two things will
interrupt an I'tikaf.
And with that, we will have finished the
book of fasting from
Kitab al-Wajiz. We started
at the beginning of Ramadan.
And
and we didn't start at the beginning of
Ramadan, really. We We
a week before Ramadan, really.
as a as a
as a preparation for Ramadan.
And then
Ramadan finished and we kept going.
And people were thinking
why are these people talking about
fasting?
Because Ramadan is over.
As if that's only to talk about
during Ramadan. So, we finished that.
We will probably
start at the beginning of the book
if we want to continue this book.
Or we can revert back to Riyadhus
Saliheen,
which is what we were doing before.
So, we'll have to discuss that,
[Arabic recitation]